you were right he says Guardian good
thing otherwise that would have been
awfully embarrassing hey youtubers it's
Charlie this week on agents of shield we
finally got our Thor crossover the team
finds an Asgardian weapon tries to find
out Thor's phone number and warden may
try to pound out their problems
literally by having sex let's talk about
our favorite moments and then I'll do my
review the Asgardian staff they find
basically gives people this berserker
rage that just makes them super powerful
which makes me wonder if it turned
normal people into Hulk like people what
would happen if the Hulk picked it up
what do you just explode in a green
cloud of rage I love the guest star
Peter McNichol actually told Ward that
it would only take a few decades for the
fix to wear off
if he didn't see Thor the dark world
Loki actually tells us that as Guardians
live for about five thousand years I
love that at the end of the episode Ward
basically deals with his problem as well
as me by just hooking up which makes me
wonder how long have they been hooking
up because that did not look like the
first time they did that let me know in
the comments but how many of you are
Coulson may shippers and did this make
you angry but on to the Hulk jokes so
there were so many hope Avengers jokes
in this I was actually kind of surprised
my favorites were one the secret is I'm
always angry when maybe basically said
this is the kind of stuff I see every
day and two when Coulson told Ward it
looks like you have some anchor time to
let it out that was basically like the
Captain America Hulk smash scene overall
though it felt like the jokes were
coming out of a machine gun I actually
wonder if Joss Whedon took a pass at the
script he's really known for that subtle
turn of phrase I also love the way the
episode deep in Asgardian mythology with
the Berserker army how hard did you
laugh whenever Peter McNichol basically
said that he stayed on earth because he
wanted to bone does that mean that earth
is like Asgard's Tahiti earth it's a
magical place the big question that we
should ask ourselves after this episode
though is what is Thor cellphone number
is he just used Heimdall instead of
having a cell phone does someone just
shout and then Heimdall hears it and
then he tells it to Thor is it like the
telephone game up in Asgard super
advanced alien race seems pretty
efficient to me but what did I think of
the episode overall I really liked it it
was not my favorite of the season but I
kind of expected to see a cameo from a
Thor the dark world character like a
minor character at least or someone in
full Asgardian costume so that was a
little disappointing but it was directed
by Jonathan Frakes from Star Trek so it
was nice to see his name pop up again
and I love the fact that the jokes were
just so rap
fire if you want to preview for the
comedy in Avengers age of Ultron this
episode is actually a good teaser I also
love the episode because it gave us a
lot of nice character development for
Ward and May and not so much the rest of
the episode I mean the episode really
was like a ward episode but it was that
last moment that basically that hookup
moment that's a giant left turn because
you wonder how many times have they been
doing this I wonder if that moment was
actually done based on notes that they
were getting that Wars character was too
boring because his character has been
pretty vanilla up to now either way -
thumbs up mission accomplished I hope
they use protection but let me know your
favorite moments from the episode were
and let me know what you think is going
on with May and Ward and has this been
going on for a long time if you haven't
seen it we're in the middle of Doctor
Who week right now I've been doing a
bunch of special videos to celebrate the
50th anniversary be sure to subscribe to
get everything I'm gonna be doing all my
normal videos this week but I also have
a lot of special stuff coming you can
click here to learn about that right now
I'm also doing a special live stream
with a bunch of my friends in the BBC
America on Saturday you can also click
here to learn more about agents of
shield this season thank you so much for
watching
high five see you guys tomorrow
you